for seven years gerald mccarthy's dog
molly helped him cope with the sudden
death of his wife
but in february molly was snatched from
his garden in broad daylight
and gerald says that losing her
companionship was a huge blow
she was part my life big part of my life
massive part of my life
you know the first thing when i finished
work every day was just
you know you wanted to get on for molly
and um my day old
all my all my days were just revolved
around you know looking after molly and
that's what they are they're part of
your life
bit like family yeah absolutely
absolutely well she was my little girl
but legally
pets are classed as property so when
they're taken it's no different to a
stolen bike
and for katie stickley whose dog trigger
was returned by the police
eight months after he was stolen this
doesn't reflect the emotional bond
between
pets and their owners it should be
classed as kidnapped because it's a
living person
even though it's not a human it's still
living
and it's still part of the family i felt
sick like that someone's actually done
that
um felt
like shaky and helpless that you can't
do nothing like it was like if one of
your children was to get stolen
on monday parliament will debate
proposals that could make it
easier for stolen pets to be reunited
with their rightful owners
like making microchip scanning
compulsory for vets
but many want the government to go
further and a petition to make
dog theft a specific offence with a
minimum two year sentence
has got more than half a million
signatures the current legislation isn't
tough enough
people can steal a pet and they might
get a fine maybe a 120 pounds something
like that
rather than you know face the full force
of the law
and that's because it doesn't take into
consideration you know the traumatic
effect it has on the family so
what we wanted to do is have the law
recognize the trauma
that's caused in a family by having a
pet stolen and
an appropriate sentence in that
situation
gerald now has a new dog but says that
nothing can replace molly he
and many others want robust punishment
for those who steal beloved pets
milanovinovic sky news